[Music]
for me
the big picture is really trying to
you know understand the things that are
going to be meaningful to my friends
to my family to my children when i'm
gone
playing with my kids or telling them a
story
i think it's just a reminder that it
matters because it's really hard to do
those little things
sometimes when you're not feeling it and
as a parent
you're usually not feeling it and so our
vision was to create a simple
beautiful baby brand to help moms
make their lives easier at first this
for several years we were just hustling
i mean we were just
working hard i was up late we were
receiving pallets to our house
it was just time after time after time
people would ask me questions
i had no idea and it felt like it was a
year
before i was asked a question that i
knew the answer to
[Music]
so i was at basis scottsdale for a
couple years teaching
and then i moved to a christian school
and i was running their missions program
during that time is when we started our
business lucy darling
so in the winter of 2012 my wife had
this idea
when she had when she was pregnant for
our daughter wanted to create a really
beautiful
product that would be helpful for us to
remember how old she was as she was
growing
a little sticker to put on her onesie
as she was getting older month by month
she said
actually because i can't find anything
maybe there's a hole in the market
that's something that we could do and
she said but we'd need to invest a
little bit of money and i thought
how much money are we talking about here
and she said a hundred dollars
i mean this is this is really going to
cut out of that teacher salary
so it was a three-day conversation about
this this seed money investment of 100
u.s dollars and i said all right i trust
you
let's let's put all the money in and so
we did we put all the 100
in and yeah i guess we haven't looked
back
[Music]
you know a lot of students have this
grand vision of
what they're going to accomplish once
they graduate from college
that was not my story my story was i
didn't really know what i wanted to do
as i finished high school my economics
teacher from my high school took us down
i can't even i think it was a lecture
from dr wolfram
and while i was on campus i was walking
by
the library and out walked clarence
thomas
that was pretty cool and so seeing him i
was like
huh i think i uh i should give a little
bit of thought to this place
and so at hillsdale immediately i just
fell in love with the place
it was maybe my junior year
but there was a restaurant there called
the saucy dog i don't know if it's still
there
but we had i think on tuesdays they had
25 cent wings night
and my roommate and i decided hey you
know what i bet we could afford to take
a professor out to dinner
you know what's he going to eat 12 wings
you know we had
tons of guys out for for this uh for
dinner
i know we had dr jackson and dr connor
and i think even
victor davis hansen came out life's hard
right there's all kinds of challenges
that we face you know
having kids is tough being married is
tough running a business is tough
and so you need to be bold enough to do
difficult things i was able to see at
hillsdale these wise men and women
who cared about me and were able to give
good counsel
so that as i've seen other challenges
challenges at work
jobs that i've had before challenges in
marriage challenges in raising
my children i've gone back to that
sort of habit that i've created which is
going to those that i that i know love
and care for me
and seeking their advice
[Music]
you know one of the the things that has
been really
helpful with our business is my wife is
very talented
she's very good at making beautiful
things and so
you know for me my goal and my job
basically from the beginning has been
how do we sell this
so at first we started the business on
etsy that's where we were doing all of
our business for the first year
and then we expanded to amazon that i
think that year
was full of a lot of challenges because
i had no idea what i was doing
i didn't know lingo i didn't know
process i didn't know anything and so i
had to figure it all out
on the fly while we were selling we
first
landed a deal with nordstrom we had i
had a hundred
page eight and a half by 11 pdf
that i had to read in order to
understand how to ship boxes to
nordstrom
and so these things were so overwhelming
at first
and we just had to plow through we were
receiving pallets to our house
on mondays we would get a pallet or two
or three delivered to the garage
and we would on that evening we would
bring everything inside and then we'd
have to label it and do all kinds of
stuff with it and then the next day
would be the pickup
and then we would have to have
everything palletized and it would be
pulled out of the garage and so it was
almost
three days a week was just that process
because we were getting bigger
and more orders i think when someone
asks you a question
you have no idea how to answer
especially when you're trying to
create a brand and a business it's it's
really humbling
because you're trying to figure out how
do i answer this correct question
correctly
but also not foolishly
since then we've been able to bring a
team together we have a warehouse and
fulfillment center
and so one of the things that's been
really neat is one
to be honest is just that my wife's a
very talented
designer it's been awesome to see
her strength working together
to to sort of give the world these
beautiful things that she has created
has been really satisfying